a town in Ruins while he's of gunfire
becoming closer to the center of Bahamut
fighters from Russia's Wagner group say
they've stepped up their attacks from
the North and the South of the Town a
win here is more symbolic than strategic
for Russian forces who've been fighting
for months
there are so units of Wagner completely
captured the village of yahidna in the
north of bakmut nice
thank you
as Russian forces take more positions
and slowly move deeper into eastern
Ukraine Western Powers have imposed more
sanctions
in a move to zero in on those who've
helped Russia to withstand sanctions the
European Union has brought in its tenth
round of sanctions which Target 87
individuals and 34 commercial and legal
entities that's in addition to the
latest U.S export restrictions and
sanctions for Russia the conflict has
become an existential issue
when all leading NATO countries have
declared their aim to inflict a
strategic defeat on us how can we not
consider their nuclear capabilities
under these circumstances they have one
goal to divide the former Soviet Union
and the Russian Federation and then
maybe they will accept us into the
so-called family of civilized Nations
but only separately piece by piece
previous rounds of sanctions against
Moscow have not achieved the desired
results as Russia has been able to find
new allies and markets and as the
rhetoric from both sides of the conflict
gets more intense peace becomes an Ever
distant possibility
Moscow